[Music]
on the racetrack the shape of a car can
give it an aerodynamic edge over the
competition
so in NASCAR races car bodies must have
uniform curves the regulations put to
focus on driver skill and make the race
a fair one they mold some of the car's
body parts from a carbon fiber and
Kevlar material first a technician
applies a release agent to a mold for
the car's front end then he sprays a
paint undercoat into it this undercoat
will eventually transfer to the
completed panel a computerized cutter
slices the carbon fiber and Kevlar
fabric into strips it produces 22 pieces
each one cut to fit a different section
of the mold the technician rolls epoxy
resin onto the fabric one strip at a
time once the strip has been completely
coated he transfers it to the mold
he tucks the fabric into the contours
and smooths out any big wrinkles he
layers the strip's three deep in a
crisscross configuration for structural
integrity a co-worker covers the carbon
fiber with perforated plastic they add
layers of absorbent polyester and thick
plastic which they glue to the edge of
the mold the insert a fitting and
connect to vacuum which sucks out air
and excess epoxy resin the polyester
material soaks up the resin as it flows
through the holes in the first plastic
layer this both smooths and compacts the
carbon fiber layers then it's into a hot
oven to bake for three hours this
activates the epoxy and combines the
layers of carbon fiber and Kevlar fabric
an employee removes the completed stock
car panel and inspects it then it's over
to a weigh station at just under 8
pounds the part is lightweight yet
virtually shatterproof
[Music]